lucas going to the mountain this is
start number 31 he's looking for his
12th win his era a touch above three and
a half lot of strikeouts he'll get
number 200 early in this game he's
walked only 51.
he holds and this ball is hit high in
the air right center
robert back at the track and he makes
the catch
by dude's going for second and he does
get in there but that ball stays in the
ballpark by about seven feet well due
dew the runner at second two outs top
one
and a pitch hit on the ground softly to
second lots of time for leori and he'll
throw to first
to end the threat matt manning on the
mound last start see how many innings he
gets a couple of starts to go when he
was with the brewers it was the cutter
the slider the 1-2 is swinging the
ground ball to the right side diving
stop by beretta's pops up throws got him
fine play he sucked for reddish he took
a hit away from abraham one two three
first ball trying to sneak through
detroit not in the shift look at that
good webbing right there snags it picks
it up a good strong throw no score
so far
this is johan monkatta
sharply into the shift and paredes is
there that's a very good second inning
for matt manning six up and six down
from manning through two passes a couple
of home runs it was a two-homer game and
it was kind of early in the year and it
was one of those games you're like oh
wow
strike three high fastball one gone
first strikeout for lucas as you throw
some high heat there's that four seam
fastball that stays upstairs gets a
little extra run tim anderson
with two down
that's past the dive of candelario and
the first hit tonight for either team is
tim anderson so you can cancel one of
the post-game shows
and figures that tim would get the first
hit he's really swung it well against
manning over their brief history
hit the ball hard slide out to right
field in the first inning this time
takes it through the left side i don't
think luis is going to be taking
fastballs this particular at bat
you don't think so no although
manning has given him trouble one two to
louise robert wave and a miss and matt
manning punches him out with a couple
minutes
it's grossman scope and cabrera for
detroit in a scoreless ball game
that's muscle to left for robbie
grossman in a leadoff single that's the
first hit for the tigers tonight bendy's
robbie grossman right here serves it out
there doesn't try and pull it the
outfield plays candelario to pull just
slightly no score fourth in england will
you help us with that
candelario to left field at a base hit
the tigers are on the board an rbi
single from jamer candelario with two
outs here in the fourth one nothing
detroit jamer candelario delivers a
two-out single here in the forge chicago
is sending up jose abreu yasmani grandal
and eloy jimenez against matt manning
here in their half of the fourth
here's the one two
on the corner to get him looking
four punch outs for matt manning his
secondary pitchers are so good tonight
they're starting to look for the express
wind up in the o2 swing and a miss got
him with a 97 mile an hour fastball away
wow
little cut
cut action i think lucas would like to
get the feel of that before it's over
and so far he hasn't had a good one
there's a slider that is number 200 for
lucas came on a slider both of them
tonight have been hot got on the side of
this
with good spin and haas could not check
it up
0-2
call strike 3 on a slider and a quick
one two three four gia lito halfway
through the fifth detroit one sucks
nothing and ryan burke comes into the
ball game off for the 34th time his era
at two and a half all things considered
he's throwing it very well the girls do
everybody's due when they step into the
box for you
on the ground this is tim
all by himself double play
burr gets out of it double play dallas
caico out of the bullpen 31 appearances
this year and era up over five he can
throw it like he threw it last time out
he's going to be a very happy man
parade is deep in the hole acrobatic
play by anderson gets away from abreu
he made a good throw except for the
bounce brayer couldn't pick it
haas is struck out twice
one two a rope to left and a base hit
for eric haas that'll drive in the
second run of the night tigers lead it
two nothing another clutch two out hit
for detroit in chicago it's like a
little cutter right here
out over the plate
strongly into left field and tigers get
another one on the board
that's a fun night there's a ground ball
fair into the left field corner moncado
went diving came up empty haas is
hustling home
and he will score
cameron delivers
an rbi double and the tigers extend
their lead to three
take a look at eric has he's running
he's got that peak i was talking about
just pump those arms back it out back it
down a little bit with your legs and
pump your arms and you'll be gliding
against grossman
fly ball right side that's actually a
line drive to right angle comes in to
grab it not before cameron scampers home
grossman delivers another two out
rbi single
and the tigers have opened up a four
nothing lead here in chicago the game
stay on this stud pull off it see how
that bat goes right where the ball went
a lot of guys pull off it that's how you
get those little stinky ground ball
ready ice cream cam take ice cream
yasmani right center field that's a good
start
extra basis for grand doll to begin the
seventh
just the third hit of the ball game for
the sox but a good way to start it off
this is a high sinker and normally high
stickers don't work very well
no chance for anybody to get to that one
monkatta one for two with a double
pitch hit hard on the ground and it
kicks past cabrera
grand all will score monkatta will end
up at second with a double
a bad hop double that ball almost took
the head off miguel cabrera now we can
see why irena would have some bad
numbers because this is bad luck
hit hard right to first base though
to white
gavin's got himself another rbi
four to two 34 driven in by gavin sheets
he got the job done and tim with an
opportunity to make things a little
closer to that act in this play on a
saturday night
off the middle in the center sheets is
on his way
it is four to three the sox again
have given the crowd a thrill to 35th
and shields
[Applause]
can find the alley like he did in each
of his last two at-bats
and a big secondary lead too montana to
left
grossman wall track oh yeah what a great
finish
to the home season
if the sox can put it away
five four in the eighth and here is liam
hendricks trying to close it out one and
two
again
this team never stops some ball game
tonight the tigers scored a run in a
fourth inning that was the first run of
the ball game they led the entire way
and then liam hendricks came on and got
the job done once again with a couple of
strikeouts in the ninth inning